when it comes right down to it food is
practically the whole story every time
words that could not be true in my own
opinion and I'll bet many of my own
colleagues sitting in the audience as
well as many of you whether your
scientist or not food is essential for
life it is fundamental to the
development of civilizations and two
societies and it's also very delicious
it's pleasurable it is celebration of
family of friends and of culture and
plays an enormous role in our life and
in many ways what we choose to put into
our body one of the most intimate
relationships that we actually have is a
deep reflection of our values and our
ethics and in turn can impart help to
shape and demonstrate and reflect the
world in which we live so good afternoon
my name is PK newbie and I'm going to
jump right into our you know what I do
because we have a limited time together
but i'll be talking about researching
and communicating nutrition in the 21st
century i'm going to begin with my own
story of food so actually it comes to it
through the very deeply pleasurable
relationship which is that i love to eat
so i grew up cooking baking baking and
gardening with my mother starting around
age 5 and i started working in
restaurants as a teenager and then I
worked in a vegetarian restaurant
cooking and my 20s to help pay for grad
school and as much as I love cooking I
decided to keep my culinary passions on
the side and instead pursue the science
of food and of course that's what we're
going to be talking talking about but
you'll see why that cook me peace is
relevant to my own story well my story
began at Columbia University where I
started and developed an
interdisciplinary program in public
health nutrition public health nutrition
is sort of as it sounds it's very wide
and broad and encompasses many many
aspects i myself was focusing on the
socio medical aspects of why what we
matter specifically thinking about the
psychological sociological and
environmental ass
X that sheep eating behavior after all
if we don't understand the drivers of
why people choose to eat what they do we
can't obviously be able to affect
lasting and meaningful change well
during that time at Columbia I had what
I hope and expect is the experience of
many my colleagues and many students at
the audience which is that I had a
life-changing experience through the
best class that I ever had it was a
class called nutrition ecology and I bet
that most of you out there are not
familiar at all with this concept and in
fact nutrition scientists are not
familiar with this concept I learned a
bit from not surprisingly from an
ecologist this was in 1995 the concept
was coined in 1980s and she had been
talking about it of course since 1960s
nutrition ecology changed the way I
think about food and indelibly altered
my entire career that experience I hope
all of you have such an experience most
of you when you think about you
nutrition you think about its effects on
your health nutrition is a basic
biological life science it's rooted in
biochemistry and physiology that's what
most nutrition scientists do that's what
I am also trained to do as well but my
social science background comes in and I
love this framework in which is not just
about health it's that environment it's
about economy it's about society aha
nutrition ecology is not just about you
when it comes to what you eat it is not
just about you and of course the word
new is in quotes because it is not a new
concept at all as you just heard however
it's slowly beginning to take hold as we
know because I think you might have
heard already today from some my
colleagues that people are increasingly
thinking about the environmental aspect
of why what we eat matters in addition
to of course many of the other public
health and influences of why what we eat
matters so then I'm go went on to focus
on health in addition to my love of food
and cooking I also did grow up and very
much interested in health so of course
nutrition is the natural science for me
I knew I wanted to be a scientist so
after
my master's degrees at Columbia I went
came here to Harvard to study
nutritional epidemiology which many of
you also already heard from my
colleagues earlier today so you know it
is the study of diet and disease in
populations nutritional epidemiology
uses largely statistics and looks at
diet and disease in large data sets and
I decided to focus my training on
obesity because as you all know in this
room it is an epidemic proportions and
that was increasingly recognized
especially at that time in the early 90s
so I knew that I wanted to get dedicate
my time there because of course obesity
is preventable and I have this slide up
just so you know that as you probably
appreciate some of them people think
obesity oh it's a risk factor for type 2
diabetes for cardiovascular disease for
metabolic syndrome and the like but it
influences an entire host of systems
throughout the body it is not a matter
of looks it is not a matter of self
esteem obesity is a matter of Health and
so despite my occasional discomfort
about talking about weight given its
unfair a role in society from that
perspective from a social perspective
from a health perspective I want people
to live a long long time so obesity is a
matter of Health and I started spending
my time there well nutritional
epidemiology is founded on what I call a
single nutrient paradigm many Sciences
including nutrition is reductionist in
nature scientists by definition reduce
things to the smallest components often
because that is what we were able to
isolate and therefore determine cause
and effect reductionism has obviously
been great a great gains in nutrition
other Sciences in understanding why
things happen of course but it left me
wanting it left me wanting as someone
who is trained in the social sciences my
first study of childhood obesity looked
exactly at those things single nutrients
fat fiber the kinds of things you would
expect well studies like those did in
fact help me develop skills as an
epidemiologist but as I mentioned they
left me very wanting given what I know
about food the reductionist model simply
did not make sense to me well I wasn't
the only one as you can imagine so
during that time this is now again still
the 90s
I came to Harvard there were colleagues
there who were starting to think about
the concept of dietary patterns so let's
go to that action I'm gonna go back for
a moment before I get to that slide
dietary patterns are sort of as they
sound it's looking at the complete diet
rather than just single nutrients or
single foods so it was a very exciting
time and I was pleased to learn from
colleagues and since that time it has
really taken off I still study obesity
and other chronic diseases but I've
spent much of my career developing these
dietary pattern methods and they really
started to take off in the 1990s and
they exponentially grew in the 21st
century they are now a validated and
common method a nutritional epidemiology
that greatly expanded our ability to see
a fax of diet on disease and by the way
it might have occurred to you in
addition to the basic scientific
limitations of reductionism we know that
the whole is greater than the sum of its
part we know that from the special
sciences we also just know that from a
very intuitive sense no one sits down to
a big bowl of nutrients for dinner right
they sit down to a meal their actual
exposure is based upon their overall
dietary pattern so i have this slide up
here simply for the benefit of my
scientific colleagues who are in the
audience specifically those in the
social sciences because these methods
are from the social sciences and i thank
you because they've been incredible in
this measurement of dietary patterns
there's just a few of them up there I'm
clearly not going to spend time on this
slide but patterns can be measured
empirically their data driven or
theoretically like as if someone's a
vegetarian or as if you use scores to
measure their diet and the light these
are just a few examples of pattern
muffins but there are many many more use
today now just as diet in which the
whole is greater than the sum of its
parts well we know that diet is part of
a larger risk profile including
lifestyle genetics and the environment
so harkening back a little bit to
nutrition ecology but this is how risk
works as well so in fact diet is part of
this whole host of factors that together
intersect and in turn acts dynamically
dynamically over time to influence our
risk and this is especially important in
understanding the etiology of calm
flex and chronic diseases like obesity
so system science and other method that
nutritional epidemiologists are
borrowing or is a big part of what I do
now so I take dietary patterns and I
used system sciences to look at overall
risk and development of obesity so these
have been very exciting areas obviously
from a research perspective what have
they shown us well my own studies which
have been in dietary pattern methods as
you've heard in chronic disease risk my
own studies which have spanned across
all many age age ranges across 33
countries across eight different cohorts
obviously just a tiny tiny amount of the
thousands and thousands of studies that
have been performed by nutrition
scientists and it has shown that a
plant-based diet is an energy balance of
course B is to lower weight less disease
higher quality of life and longevity now
at the same time our colleagues in the
environmental and agricultural sciences
have shown that that very same diet is
most protective when it comes to
protecting our planet and that's good
news and again we see that intersection
of nutritional ecological thinking so
where does that leave us well in closing
we know that this is protective so of
course that begs the question why are
people slowly killing themselves and a
planet through suboptimal diets
obviously that's a big question when I
spend a lot of time thinking about and
far beyond the space and scope of the
time I have with you now so I leave you
with one thought alone which is that
despite the phenomenal gains in the
digital revolution the access the volume
of information there's a huge amount of
anti science and junk science out there
so that's why I became passionate about
communicating nutrition meeting people
where they're at through both television
blogging medium like bring it back to
cooking harkening Derek box the previous
president of Harvard University to go
beyond the ivory tower to changing the
way people eat leading to a healthier
people and healthier planet so leave you
again with Vonnegut's words when it
comes right down to it food is probably
the whole story every time and to that i
will add how that story ends is up to us
it is up to you vote with your vote but
your fork be the change in the world you
wish to city